Speaker 1: Let's go to Spencer from
California. Spencer, you're on next.
Speaker 5: Hey, David. First-Time Caller. Pleasure
to be on. And one of the things I'm wondering
is I was watching one of the interviewers,
the interviews that you did last week where
the interviewee, I think, raised the possibility
of having a third political party forming in the
U.S. sometime in the next couple of years. So
I'm wondering what your thoughts are on that.
And if you think that that's a feasible thing.
Speaker 1: I am very supportive of third parties.
I think we are so myopically limited in the US by
having only two parties. I've also said that that
in order for third parties to really be viable
in the United States, we need to move in the
direction of ideally some kind of ranked choice or
transferable voting system where people wouldn't
worry. If I vote third party, I might be helping
the person I'm the most against. For example,
if as someone on the left you vote for the Green
Party, you might actually help the Republican by
taking votes from the Democrats. So we need some
kind of transferable or ranked choice system
number one and number two, we need to go towards
public financing of elections that will even
the playing field in terms of what is able to be
spent by parties because initially third parties
would be at a massive financial disadvantage.
So I support third parties. I would love to
have strong parties in the United States other
than Democrats and Republicans. Without the two
reforms I mentioned, I don't know how it happens.
Speaker 5: OK. Yeah, that makes sense. And then I
guess just another quick question, though, I've
been following your channel for a while and I
see all these clips of people like Mike Pilou and
Rudy Giuliani. Giuliani always talking about how
evidence is supposedly coming out soon,
very senior fraud cases or whatever.
Yeah. So I'm wondering, do you think they're
eventually going to pivot away from that as
they approach the next election cycle
and just focus on winning elections?
Speaker 1: I don't know. It almost I almost am
wondering at this point if they'll just keep
saying the evidence is just around the corner
until they're dead. I don't know. They don't
seem to have any off ramp from repeating that
we're about to get all the evidence they.
It's bizarre. I don't know. I don't
know when they're going to stop talking
about it.
Speaker 5:
Got you. Thanks for taking my call, David.
Speaker 1: All right, thanks, Spencer.
Great to hear from you. That's Spencer from
California. Very powerful series of callers today.